STORY, WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THIS IS THE 13TH NIGHT IN A ROW
THAT WE HAVE LET THE SHOW WITH
THE BRETT KAVANAUGH STORY.
IT LOOKS LIKE AFTER DELAYS AND
COUNTLESS TWISTS IN THE SAGA, IT
MAY FINALLY BE COMING TO A
CONCLUSION.
THE FBI INVESTIGATION, THE ONE
THAT SENATOR JEFF FLAKE DEMANDED
LAST FRIDAY APPEARS TO BE
WRAPPING UP.
A FINAL VOTE COULD BE HELD THIS
WEEKEND, THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE IS, AFTER ALL
THAT WE HAVE LEARNED, THERE ARE
STILL BASIC QUESTIONS THAT
REMAIN UNANSWERED.
SEVERAL MONTHS TO THE CORE
ALLEGATION HERE, THE ONES THAT
CHRISTINE FORD MADE MORE THAN
TWO WEEKS AGO.
YESTERDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, FOX NEWS
OBTAINED A WRITTEN DECLARATION
FROM AN EX-BOYFRIEND OF
CHRISTINE FORD'S.
IN THAT DECLARATION THE
EX-BOYFRIEND SAID THAT FORD ONCE
COACHED A FRIEND THROUGH A
POLYGRAPH EXAM TO HELP HER GET A
FEDERAL JOB.
IF TRUE, THAT WOULD CONTRADICT
WHAT FORD TOLD CONGRESS.
THE MAN ALSO SAID THAT DURING
THEIR ENTIRE SIX YEAR
RELATIONSHIP, FORD NEVER
MENTIONED IT BEING A VICTIM OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR ANY OTHER KIND
OF TRAUMA AND SAID SHE FLEW ON
AIRPLANES MANY TIMES INCLUDING
SMALL PROP PLANES AROUND HAWAII.
YOU WILL RECALL THAT SHE WAS TOO
AFRAID TO FLY TO COME TO
WASHINGTON.
SHE ALSO CLAIMS SHE WAS A
CLAUSTROPHOBIC AND HE CLAIMED
THAT SHE WAS NOT AFRAID OF
ENCLOSED SPACES.
ARE THESE CLAIMS TRUE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
FOR DISPUTES THEM AND THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THEM
INDEPENDENTLY BUT THERE'S ALSO
NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT FORD'S
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
AND THAT'S A POINT, WE NEED TO
KNOW MORE BUT WE DON'T KNOW MORE
BECAUSE NO ONE IS ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS.
IN MANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE STILL HAVEN'T
SEEN FORD'S THERAPY NOTES.
FORD'S TEAM IS ONLY NOW AT THE
LAST MOMENT COVERING TO REVEAL
THESE BUT ONLY IF THE FBI AGREES
TO INTERVIEW CHRISTINE FORD.
I WANT THESE NOTES TURNED OVER
AT THE BEGINNING OF ALL THIS?
IF THE GOAL WOULD HAVE BEEN TO
GET TO THE TRUTH, THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN.
WHY HAS FORD TOLD DIFFERENT
STORIES?
IT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT
BEARS DIRECTLY ON HER
CREDIBILITY.
AND HER CREDIBILITY IS THE ONLY
REASON TO BELIEVE HER STORY IS
TRUE.
AND THERE ARE OTHER OBVIOUS
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS, HERE'S
THIS ONE.
FORD SAID THE ASSAULT DEFINED
HER ENTIRE LIFE.
APPARENTLY, SHE THOUGHT ABOUT IT
EVERY DAY.
IT DEFINED HER ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND ALL OF HER
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS AND YET,
SHE SAYS SHE TOLD NOT A SINGLE
OTHER HUMAN BEING AROUND ABOUT
IT FOR A FULLY 30 YEARS.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
IN A "WASHINGTON POST" PROFILE,
FORD SAYS THAT SHE "CAME TO
UNDERSTAND HER ASSAULT AND ITS
SIGNIFICANCE DURING A THERAPY
SESSION."
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
THIS IS A CENTRAL QUESTION
BECAUSE MOST THE PSYCHIATRIST
CONSIDER RECOVERED MEMORIES
HOWEVER SINCERE ROUGHLY AS
RELIABLE AS DREAMS.
IT'S WORTH GETTING A CLEAR
ANSWER ON THAT BUT SO FAR,
NOBODY HAS BECAUSE NOBODY HAS
ASKED THAT QUESTION.
WHY IS THAT?
WHEN AN ADULT MAKES A SERIOUS
ALLEGATION ASKING REAL QUESTION
QUESTIONS, WHAT IS THE CORRECT
RESPONSE?
IT'S NOT VICTIM SHAMING.
IN FACT, IT'S PATRONIZING NOT
TO.
WE DON'T CONSIDER IT CHRISTINE
FORD A CHILD, BUT MANY OF HER
ADVOCATES CLEARLY DO.
THE PRESS OBVIOUSLY DOES.
INSTEAD OF GATHERING FACTS ABOUT
THE STORY THEY ARE BUSY
MORALIZING AND LECTURING THE
REST OF US ABOUT HOW BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S VERY EXISTENCE
PROVES THAT AN ENTIRE CLASS OF
PEOPLE AS EVIL.
JUST THE OTHER DAY,
DONALD TRUMP JR. MADE THE POINT
THAT WHAT HE'S BEEN WATCHING ON
TELEVISION MAKES HIM FEAR FOR
HIS SONS.
WATCH.
>> WHEN I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW, IT'S SCARY.
>> WHO ARE YOU SCARED FOR, YOUR
SONS OR YOUR DAUGHTERS?
>> RIGHT NOW MY SONS.
WHEN THE OTHER SIDE WEAPONIZE IS
MADE AGAINST MEN AND SAYS, 40
YEARS LATER WE CAN BRING IT UP
AND YOU DID SOMETHING IN
HIGH SCHOOL BUT NO ONE
REMEMBERS, IT SHOULD DISQUALIFY
YOU FROM EVER DOING ANYTHING
AGAIN, IT DIMINISHES THE ROLE
CLAIMS.
>> Tucker: MAYBE YOU AGREE
WITH THAT AND MAYBE YOU DON'T
BUT IT'S HARDLY A CRAZY POINT.
AND THEY ARE ATTACKING AN ENTIRE
ETHNIC GROUP ON THE BASIS OF THE
CITY.
>> EVERY NIGHT I CRY MYSELF TO
SLEEP OVER THE FEET OF WHITE MEN
IN AMERICA.
IT'S SUCH GARBAGE.
IF YOU SEXUALLY ASSAULT SOMEONE
IN HIGH SCHOOL, YOUR LIFE SHOULD
BE RUINED.
ALL THIS WHINING ABOUT THE POOR
PLIGHT OF THE WHITE MAN IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> YOU ARE HEARING A LOT OF THIS
FILTH RECENTLY AND IT'S WRONG
BECAUSE RACISM IS ALWAYS WRONG
NO MATTER WHO IT'S AIMED AT.
YOU SHOULD NOT ATTACK PEOPLE FOR
THEIR IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTICS,
PERIOD.
YOU SHOULDN'T EVER REDUCE PEOPLE
TO THEIR SKIN COLOR BECAUSE THEY
ARE MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
TO TREAT PEOPLE AS INDIVIDUALS,
UNIQUE HUMAN BEINGS, THAT'S
EXACTLY THE ARGUMENT YOU COULD
HAVE MADE IN 1960 AGAINST BULL
CONNOR.
IF THEY'D BEEN THERE, YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE MADE THAT
ARGUMENT.
IT'S THE SAME ARGUMENT WE ARE
MAKING TODAY.
IT WAS TRUE THEN, IT'S TRUE NOW
AND IT ALWAYS WILL BE TRUE.
YOU DON'T THINK YOU'D HAVE TO
SAY SOMETHING THAT OBVIOUS IN A
DEVELOPED COUNTRY, ONE THAT
LITERALLY HAS A STATUE OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING ON THE
NATIONAL MALL.
BUT YOU DO HAVE TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE NO CHOICE.
AND FOR THE CRIME OF ARGUING
AGAINST RACISM WE ARE DENOUNCED
BY THE LEFT AS, YES, RACIST.
THAT'S INSANE.
IT'S THE MIRROR IMAGE OF THE
TRUTH AND, THERE IS THE REASON
THAT THEY ARE SAYING IT.
PEOPLE ARE EASIER TO CONTROL
WHEN THEY ARE DIVIDED INTO
TRIBES SORTED BY COLOR.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
IT'S ALSO THAT EVIL, JUST LIKE
THE RACISM THEY ARE PEDALING TO